there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people so when they
needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
welcome back everyone its trailer week
that's right there's going to be a whole
bunch of trailers coming up in the next
week including the Black Widow trailer
so I'll break down what that is when
everything is happening and there's a
special Marvel phase for Comic Con panel at Brazil Comic Con where Kevin Feige is
personally going to unveil more details
about the future of the MCU that he has
not revealed already of course I'll be
covering all that stuff in my videos
next week too so be sure to subscribe to
get everything
we're still doing that infinity saga
giant box set giveaway - I will be
naming the first giveaway winner for
that next week all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
biggest theory about what the black
widow post credit scene is going to be
the reason why all this stuff is
happening is because Brazil comic-con is
next weekend in the studio's typically
use that as their big convention at the
end of the year to unveil trailers for
all the big movies next year as per
usual Marvel is doing a big panel there
in addition to DC but this year Kevin
Feige is going personally to
quote-unquote
unveil future details about the MCU that
he is not already but we also know
what's going on with the black widow
trailer so I'll break that down first
then I'll talk about the other stuff
that Kevin Feige is going to reveal this
is just the d23 footage so keep in mind
that it'll be much more complete as a
trailer than just a couple scenes strung
together but this is the footage that
they've showed up previously it started
with a montage of Black Widow in the
other Marvel movies so far doing
voiceover saying I used to have nothing
then I got this job this family I was
better because of it I've made mistakes
I can't go back and then the Marvel
Studios logo all that dialogue was just
borrowed from her Avengers end game
dialogue before they went into the
quantum brown and she sacrificed herself
then text flashes on the screen saying
budapest finally revealing part of
what's happened in budapest there are a
couple different times that Black Widow
has been involved in budapest one in the
past when she ran into Hawkeye for the
first time and then one closer to
present-day that we'll see during the
course of the Black Widow movie then
there's a scene of Black Widow walking
into an old apartment building with her
gun drawn looking for Jelena Bulova in
one of the apartment rooms she hears her
say from the other side of the wall I
know you're out there that she replies I
know you know she turns the corner with
her gun drawn still being very cautious
and Jelena Bulova is standing there and
says is that what we are grown
they tell each other to put their guns
down neither one does this is really
tense beat then they steal each other's
guns using the exact same move at the
exact same time because they both been
trained in the red-room program so they
know all the same moves this happens a
couple times with both of them stealing
each other's guns before they start
their big fist fight so then they start
brawling as you see during this footage
even though they're very consistent with
Black Widows fighting style across the
Marvel movies they have the John wick
fight coordinator so it just extra down
and dirty it feels a lot like Bucky
versus Captain America in Winter Soldier
but with Black Widows fighting style
they both wind up knocking each other
out they pass out on the ground they cut
to a scene of them pouring drinks for
each other and Black Widow says good to
see you too says because they refer to
each other like sisters because they
came up in the red room together then
she says you just had to come to
Budapest didn't you then they cut to a
montage of a bunch of different scenes
clipped together there's one with Black
Widow running across this beautiful
mountain range by herself then there's
another scene with a bunch of other
Black Widow Red Room agents pointing
guns at her while she's on the rooftop
of a building then there's a separate
motorcycle chase that looks like it's
right out of a Mission Impossible movie
finally there's the scene of Black Widow
in a car that gets smashed into a bridge
in the middle of the night this scene
here it gets flipped over the cars
burning but she looks out and taskmaster
is coming for her she shoots but he
pulls out his shield to stop the bullets
the fighting begins they have a very
similar fighting style and because of
taskmasters moves he catches on to her
moves even quicker and learns to
anticipate and beat her after a few more
moves they both kneel down and then look
up at each other in the same position as
if they were mirrored so this is
basically him just using that ability
this is the concept art and then this is
the footage that we've seen of him on
set so far obviously this will be tuned
up quite a bit with special effects but
like I said the footage they show up in
the actual trailer next week will be way
way bigger what I'm anticipating is is
that it'll probably be Tuesday morning
at the ass crack of dawn on Good Morning
America which is typically where they
released their Marvel trailers this week
around Thanksgiving if it's not
something special like last year for
Avengers endgame they released it on a
Friday that's not going to happen this year
for those that are still a little
confused about how the Black Widow movie
can exist when Natasha sacrificed
herself during Avengers end
the whole concept of this movie is that
it takes place during the past but there
will be some moments that take place in
present day because it is a Marvel phase
for movie and obviously the whole idea
is to push the timeline forward most of
the stuff that's happening in the past
is a combination of flashbacks to her
childhood growing up in the Red Room we
have a couple deleted scenes from
Avengers age of Ultron that detail that
still expand upon I'll play those clips
in a second but the present day of the
movie will mostly take place between the
events of Captain America Civil War in
Avengers endgame but because a big part
of the Black Widow movie is her trying
to save Jelena Bulova from the Red Room
the same way that Hawkeye gave her an
offer for a better way to live people
are now theorizing that the blonde hair
in infinity war has something to do with
her time with Jelena Bulova now I do
think that Jelena Bulova will be
important to Marvel phase 4 in any
Thunder Bulls or Dark Avengers project
that they do in the future but as wide
open a theory crafting we'll talk about
it more when they released the actual
trailer I'm also really really excited
to see Alexei szostak Hoff played by
David Harbor he's the Russian version of
Captain America called Red Guardian you
can kind of see his suit here on the
poster he has a full-on Russian red
version of a Captain America suit with a
shield to match here those deleted
scenes with Black Widow from Avengers
age of Ultron for her backstory
again your braixen only the bankable
once you're made of marble we'll
celebrate after the graduation ceremony
what if I fail most of all that stuff
came from joss whedon they made him cut that before the actual movie came out
but getting into the big Marvel comic
con panel the Kevin Feige is doing next
week the reason why this is a special
big deal is because normally he just
sends a pre-recorded greeting saying
thank you for coming to the convention
here's a trailer watch some footage the
only reason he would go in person is if
he's going to be revealing a lot of
extra new details that he hasn't
revealed already they've already
revealed all of the Marvel phase 4 movie
dates and all the TV shows that are
going to be on Disney plus the extras that
we're still wondering about or all the
big phase 5 dates starting in 2022 I did
a video a little while ago about
Avengers 5 in the 5 new mystery movie
dates that they've revealed and what
those are probably going to be we know
Black Panther 2 is going to be May 2022
right now there's a rumor a lot of
people believe that Fantastic Four is
going to be the next big movie after Black
Panther so we're all kind of waiting for
an official Fantastic Four announcement
I'm not expecting him to reveal that but
that would be amazing there's also a
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 which
based on their production start date is
probably going to be February 2023 they've already told us they're going to do Captain Marvel 2
he might reveal when that's
going to happen we know spider-man 4 is
going to happen but I don't think
they're going to talk about that until
after spider-man 3 comes out then
there's the blade movie we still don't
know when that's coming out he could
reveal when that's going to be so aside
from that he'll probably show off some
different Black Widow footage that's not
going to be in the trailer that we'll
watch next week and maybe some early
eternals footage because they're deep
into shooting that right now so they
probably have something to show off
there's been all kinds of rumors about
post-credit scenes for Thunderbolts and
future Dark Avengers stuff through
general Ross I know everyone's wondering
if he might become a version of Red Hulk
eventually in the movies
the cool thing about William Hurt is
that the only reason why he took the job
on the first Incredible Hulk film and
signed the contract and came back for
all these films is because he is a huge
fan of the
comics and all those family of
characters so I don't think he would
sign up to be Thunderbolt Ross without
the idea that someday he might get to
play a version of Red Hulk but you have
to remember when he signed that original
contract that was back during Incredible
Hulk era Edward Norton told us that they
were actually supposed to be three
Incredible Hulk films and the leader was
supposed to be the villain of the sequel
for those of you wondering what happened to the leader after that movie
so whatever happens at the Marvel Comic
Con panel next week I will totally do a
breakdown video for that in addition to
the black widow trailer video there's a
couple other DC trailers that are
dropping too but I'll just talk about
those when I do my next DC video so no
worries if you have any special requests
for videos next week for all the
trailers just let me know in the
comments below while you wait for
everything click here for that alternate
ending to Avengers endgame where Iron
Man meets his daughter in the soul world
and click here for my Mandalorian
episode 4 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!